Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. And today we are arriving in the fair land of Belgium and Dominic. We have had one Belgian on The Rest Is History, haven't we? And he is absolutely a fan favourite. Bart van Leeuw, author of a sensational book called The Burgundians. And we have got Bart back.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目的权限，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。您好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。今天我们来到了比利时这片美丽的土地，多米尼克。我们之前在《历史的余烬》节目中邀请过一位比利时嘉宾，对吧？而且他绝对是粉丝们的最爱：《勃艮第人》这本轰动一时的小作的作者巴特·范·卢（Bart van Leeuw）。我们把巴特请回来了。
Bart, thanks so much for joining us. Hello, Dominic and Tom. Nice to be here. Hello, Bart. Lovely to have you. So your book, The Burgundians, for those people who haven't read it, is an absolute feast of a book. And your appearance on our podcast, if anything, was even better because you talked constantly, as I remember, for 60 minutes. Tom and I barely said anything.
巴特，非常感谢你能来。大家好，多米尼克和汤姆。很高兴能来到这里。你好，巴特。很高兴你能来。那么，对于那些还没读过你那本《勃艮第人》的人来说，这是一本绝对的饕餮盛宴。你上次上我们的播客，如果说有什么不同的话，那就是表现得甚至更好，因为我记得你连续滔滔不绝地讲了60分钟。我和汤姆几乎什么都没说。
No, it was perfect. It was absolutely perfect. But there was one thing at the end of that Burgundian podcast that you were disappointed by, I remember. You said, I haven't talked at all about Flemish art and about Jan van Eyck. So we thought, in this World Cup marathon, as we approach the subject of Belgium, we thought, well, let's do Jan van Eyck with Bart van Leeuwen. But here's the question. Is he Belgian? Is he Belgian? Yes, yes. Before I start, I want to address myself to historical purists, because they would probably argue that Jan van Eyck, the greatest painter in Northern, Western and Central Europe before 1500, is not a real Belgian since Belgium was created in 1830 and he lived, as far as we know, in the 15th century.
不，那很完美。绝对完美。但我也记得，在那期关于勃艮第的播客结束时，有一件事让你感到遗憾。你说：“我一点也没谈论弗兰芒艺术，也没有谈论扬·范·埃克。”所以我们在这次世界杯马拉松节目中，当我们将话题引向比利时时，我们想：“好吧，那就和巴特·范·卢一起聊聊扬·范·埃克。”但问题来了：他是比利时的吗？他是比利时的吗？是的，是的。在我开始之前，我想向历史纯粹主义者说几句，因为他们可能会争辩说，扬·范·埃克——这位1500年之前北欧、西欧和中欧最伟大的画家——并不是一个真正的比利时人，因为比利时是在1830年才建立的，而据我们所知，他生活在15世纪。
Well, here's what I would like to say to them. When we look at the map of Europe at the end of the Middle Ages, we see two main powers on the continent, France and the Holy Roman Empire, let's say Germany, to simplify things. And in between, a border that seems to last forever. But then in the course of the 4th and 15th century, we see appear a new state, the Low Countries, the cradle of what later on will become the Netherlands and Belgium, an incredible geopolitical achievement that we owe to the Dukes of Burgundy, who I talked about a year ago in your podcast. And I would like to add this thing, that if the Dukes of Burgundy didn't puzzle together
好吧，我想对他们说的是：当我们看着中世纪末期的欧洲地图时，我们看到大陆上有两个主要政权：法国和神圣罗马帝国（为了简单起见，我们不妨称之为德国）。而在两者之间，是一条似乎永远存在的边界。但随后，在公元4世纪（注：原文如此，可能为14世纪之误）和15世纪期间，我们看到一个新国家崛起——低地国家，也就是后来成为荷兰和比利时的摇篮。这是一个令人难以置信的地缘政治成就，我们要归功于勃艮第公爵们，我一年前在你们的播客里谈到过他们。我想补充一点，如果勃艮第公爵们在中世纪末期没有把低地国家拼凑在一起，
the low countries at the end of the Middle Ages, we could never have invented Belgium in 1830. Moreover, if we talk about Jan van Eyck, nobody will think the Netherlands. Everybody will think Flemish primitives at the famous schools of painters in Flanders, Brabant, Hainaut. And on the contrary, when we say Vermeer or Rembrandt, everybody will immediately say the Netherlands, 12 points. And indeed, van Eyck was born in current Belgium, probably learns his craftsmanship in current Belgium, and will make his most known masterpieces in Bruges and Ghent, current Belgium.
我们在1830年就绝不可能创造出比利时。此外，当我们谈论扬·范·埃克时，没有人会想到荷兰。每个人都会想到弗兰芒早期大师，想到弗兰芒、布拉班特、埃诺那些著名的画派学校。相反，当我们说维米尔或伦勃朗时，每个人都会立刻说“荷兰，12分”。确实，范·埃克出生在现在的比利时，很可能是在现在的比利时学的手艺，并且在现在的比利时城市布鲁日和根特创作了他最著名的杰作。
So I think that in this World Cup of History, I think he can run for Belgium, just under two conditions. If we agree that Jan van Eyck can put on the shirt of the Red Devils, we know that the Bran and Hazard, they need some help. If he does so, we will carefully see to it that he's also wearing a Burgundian captain's band. Yes. Yellow and blue colours of Burgundy, and that on the front
所以我想，在这场历史世界杯中，他完全可以代表比利时出场，不过有两个前提条件。如果我们一致同意扬·范·埃克可以穿上红魔（比利时国家队昵称）的球衣——我们知道德布劳内和阿扎尔确实需要一些帮助——如果他这么做，我们会仔细确保他同时也戴上勃艮第队长的臂章。是的。带有勃艮第黄蓝两色的臂章，并且在他的球衣
of his shirt, we'll put the unforgettable logo of the Golden Fleece. Yes. So the Golden Fleece, the Golden Fleece is the order created by the habsburgs is that right is the habsburgs on the bank dandy is dominic not the habsburgs i think they're dominic and dominic and tom eminent historians i ask you officially do you agree that under that circumstances jan van eyck can run for Belgium. Yes, absolutely. That's, well, it would ruin this episode if we disagreed, wouldn't it? So, Bart, in the episode you did for us on the Burgundians, you gave us the image of
正面，我们会印上金羊毛骑士团那令人难忘的标志。是的。所以金羊毛，金羊毛是哈布斯堡王朝创立的骑士团，对吗？多米尼克，那是哈布斯堡王朝的吗？不是哈布斯堡王朝，多米尼克。我认为是……多米尼克和汤姆，作为杰出的历史学家，我正式请教二位：你们是否同意在这种情况下，扬·范·埃克可以代表比利时出场？是的，绝对同意。这……好吧，如果我们不同意，这期节目就被毁了，对吧？所以，巴特，你在为我们制作的关于勃艮第人的节目中，给我们描绘了这样一个形象：
this spectacularly sophisticated court, full of beauty and glamour and gold and great feasts and a lot of dwarfs, as I remember. Yes. So Van Eyck, he becomes the court painter, is he, to the court of Burgundy? Is that his role? Yes, that's maybe the centre of what I want to say, that he will be the court painter of Philip the Good, and that he, later on I would like to talk about that, that even he played a main role
一个极其精致的宫廷，充满美感、魅力、黄金、盛大的宴会，我记得还有很多侏儒。是的。所以，范·埃克成了宫廷画师，是吗？他是勃艮第宫廷的画师？这是他的角色吗？是的，这也许就是我想表达的核心：他将成为菲利普良公爵（Philip the Good）的宫廷画师，而且——我稍后想谈谈这一点——他甚至在
in those feasts, in those Burgundian banquets. But maybe we can start at the beginning. Yes, let's begin at the beginning. Maybe it's an idea because it's incredibly difficult to talk about somebody who lived in the 15th century. And maybe it's an idea just to travel in his footsteps. And that's not easy. Some of my allegations will be hypothetical.
那些庆典和勃艮第式的宴会中扮演了主要角色。不过也许我们可以从头讲起。是的，让我们从头讲起。这或许是个好主意，因为要谈论一个生活在15世纪的人是极其困难的。也许最好的办法就是沿着他的足迹去旅行。但这并不容易。我的一些推断将是假设性的。
We are no stranger to hypotheticals. We've had some ludicrous claims made on this podcast before, mainly by Tom, actually, about Costa Rican politics. So, Bart, you have complete freedom. Yes. And at the end, let's say that we will talk about the most emblematic piece of art, the Ghent Altar piece, the Adoration of the Mystic Lamp, the Apotheosis of Medieval Art.
我们对假设并不陌生。我们以前在这个播客里听过一些荒谬的说法，主要其实是汤姆关于哥斯达黎加政治的言论。所以，巴特，你有完全的自由。是的。最后，我们不妨谈谈那件最具标志性的艺术品——根特祭坛画（Ghent Altarpiece），即《神秘羔羊之崇拜》（The Adoration of the Mystic Lamp），中世纪艺术的巅峰之作。
And maybe before we start, listeners, this is just a tip. It could be interesting. From time to time, everybody who is listening, you can pause this podcast and quickly look up the painting i'm talking about and then you come back to the podcast i'm going to do that right now the key thing is you must come back to the podcast i think multitask look at it and listen all right bart off you go let's begin at the beginning our incredibly gifted painter was born in mazag that's the eastern part of current Belgium. And how do we know that?
也许在我们开始之前，听众朋友们，这只是个小建议，可能会很有趣。在听的过程中，大家可以随时暂停播客，快速查阅我正在谈论的那幅画，然后再回到播客中来。我现在就要这么做了。关键是，你必须回到播客中来。我想大家可以一边多任务处理，一边看图一边听。好了，巴特，请继续。让我们从头讲起：我们这位才华横溢的画家出生在马泽克（Maaseik），那是现比利时的东部地区。我们是怎么知道这一点的呢？
Well, that's quite interesting. In 1435, he's making a portrait of Cardinal Albergatti. And what is fascinating, we still have his draft, made with a silver pen, which for 21st century eyes has the moral is the same effect, I think, as a pencil. And on his draft, Jan kept a written reminder of the colors he would have to use for certain passages when later on he would begin the real painting. Indications such as as gray with ochre overtones for the hair on Albergatti's head,
嗯，这非常有趣。1435年，他正在绘制阿尔贝加蒂枢机主教（Cardinal Albergatti）的肖像。最迷人的是，我们至今仍保留着他的草图，是用银针画的。在21世纪的人看来，这种笔触的效果我想和铅笔差不多。在这张草图上，扬留下了一些文字备忘，记下了他稍后开始真正作画时某些部分需要使用的颜色。比如这样的指示：阿尔贝加蒂头部的头发用带有土黄色调的灰色，
or very pale white is purple for the lips. And so on. For instance, for the eyes, I like it a lot. He's talking about a yellowish brown tone around the black of the pupil. And he writes down that there is a bluish glow around the white, and he called the white of the eye itself yellowish. And in making the beautiful definitive portrait of 1438, he clearly did not let his own advice go unhealed.
或者用非常苍白的白色调紫色来画嘴唇。诸如此类。例如对于眼睛，我非常喜欢——他谈到了瞳孔黑色周围的一种黄褐色调。他写道，白色眼球周围有一种泛蓝的光晕，他把眼球本身的白色称为微黄色。在创作1438年那幅美丽而定稿的肖像画时，他显然没有将自己的这些建议置若罔闻。
But what makes it really interesting is by unraveling his scribbled color suggestions from 1435, language historians have concluded that van Eyck, Eyck, if you pronounce him in the English way, must have spoken a Maasland dialect.
但真正令人感兴趣的是，通过梳理他1435年涂抹的那些颜色建议，语言学家们得出结论：如果按照英语发音的话，范·埃克（Eyck）一定说的是马斯兰（Maasland）方言。
And that confirms the theory that the painter was born in Maasland in today's Eastern Belgium. And there is, of course, also his name itself that seems to support this line of reasoning. And that's nice. I like it to see how linguistics and art history can make a beautiful couple. But you criticized, or there was a hint there, that you don't pronounce Van Eyck like we do. Yes, yes. You say Van Eyck, but he's Van Eyck. Van Eyck. Van Eyck.
这就证实了这样一种理论：这位画家出生在今天比利时东部的马斯兰。当然，他的名字本身也似乎支持这种推理逻辑。这很美妙，我喜欢看到语言学和艺术史如何能够结成美满的姻缘。不过你刚才批评了，或者说暗示了，我们对范·埃克的发音和你们不一样。是的，是的。你们说范·埃克（Van Eyck），但他其实是范·埃克。范·埃克。范·埃克。
Van Eyck. All right. Tom, you do it? Van Eyck. That's ridiculous. It's like if you want to pronounce my name, you say Van Loo. It's not nice in English, but you should say Van Loo. Van Loo.
范·埃克。好吧。汤姆，你来读一下？范·埃克。这太荒谬了。就像如果你想念我的名字，你会说范·卢（Van Loo）。这在英语里听起来不太好，但你应该说范·卢。范·卢。
Van Eck, Van Loo. Okay. We've educated ourselves and we will try to do better in future. Yes. All right. So he's from, I don't even want to say it actually. Mazek. And we know that because of the linguistic analysis.
范·埃克，范·卢。好的。我们受教育了，以后会尽量做好。好的。所以他是来自……我甚至都不想说这个词了。马泽克。我们通过语言学分析知道了这一点。
So how does he make his, Do we know about his family? Do we know about his social background? All these kinds of things? Yes, we know a little bit. We know his wife because we have the portrait of his wife. He's still in Bruges. Margaretha Van Eyck. And we know we had a daughter.
那么他是如何……我们了解他的家庭吗？我们了解他的社会背景吗？所有这些事情？是的，我们了解一点。我们知道他的妻子，因为我们有他妻子的肖像。她当时还在布鲁日。玛格丽塔·范·埃克（Margaretha Van Eyck）。我们也知道他有一个女儿。
But we don't know a lot of things. We found the address of his studio, his atelier in Bruges. And the rest we know about Van Eyck is thanks to the Burgundian accounts, the Burgundian archives, where he's been paid. And it's like that, that we can make ourselves a little idea of what his life should have been. What happens next, we don't know for sure, but specialists agree that in all probability,
但有很多事情我们并不清楚。我们找到了他在布鲁日的画室地址。关于范·埃克，我们了解的其他情况都要归功于勃艮第的账目和勃艮第的档案，上面有向他支付薪水的记录。正因如此，我们才能对他的生活有一个大致的了解。接下来发生了什么，我们无法百分之百确定，但专家们一致认为，在所有可能性中，
he will complete his craftsmanship in Liège, that's today the most important city in Eastern Belgium, just by following the river Meuse, La Meuse, the Maas, to Liège. And some say that he painted the famous, and there you go, listeners, the famous Madonna with Chancellor you go, listeners, the famous Madonna with Chancellor Roland, 1335, in one of the churches of the city. I want to explain that.
他是在列日（Liège）完成了他的手艺学习。列日是今天比利时东部最重要的城市，只需顺着默兹河（La Meuse，即马斯河）一直走到列日即可。有人说，他画了那幅著名的——听众朋友们，注意了——著名的《罗兰大臣与圣母》（Madonna with Chancellor Rolin，1335年，注：实为1435年），画在当地的一座教堂里。我想解释一下这一点。
What do we see on this painting? In front, we see the second most powerful man in the Duchy, Chancellor Roland, is the prime minister of Philip the Good. He appears in a mink-trimmed gold brocade robe, and he may be kneeling at the preacher, but we see no sense of any humility whatsoever. He's directly, without appealing to a patron saying to mediate, no, he focuses directly on Jesus, and Christ blesses him approvingly from the lap of his holy mother. And in the background, and that's what I want to talk about, we see a beautiful landscape, a kind of fairy tale of landscape
在这幅画上我们看到了什么？在前方，我们看到了公国中第二权势滔天的人——罗兰大臣，他是菲利普良公爵的首相。他身穿镶有水貂皮的金锦缎长袍，虽然他可能正跪在祈祷，但我们完全看不到一丝一毫的谦卑。他没有通过任何中间人或赞助人去祈求转圜，不，他直接将目光投向了耶稣，基督从他神圣母亲的膝头赞许地祝福着他。而在背景中——这正是我想要谈论的——我们看到了一片美丽的风景，一种童话般的风景，
with mountains, churches, palaces beside a mighty river. It looks like what you could see when you are in the church tower of St. Bartholomew of Jerzy. But if you look better, you also see the dome of Utrecht. You see snowy mountaintops we don't have that in belgium it can be liège alone and that's right van naak mixes his memories he's not only the greatest realist of his time i will talk about that later on but he's also a master in sampling faces landscape memories and that makes him really modern, I think.
有山脉、教堂、宫殿，坐落在大河之畔。这看起来就像你站在热尔齐（Jérzy，注：应为赫尔河畔圣巴托洛缪教堂等地的景色）圣巴托洛缪教堂的塔楼上所能看到的景象。但如果你仔细看，你还能看到乌得勒支的圆顶。你还能看到雪山山顶——我们在比利时可没有雪山——这只能是列日。没错，范·埃克融合了他的记忆。他不仅是他那个时代最伟大的现实主义者——我稍后会谈到这一点——而且他还是一个将面孔、风景记忆进行“采样”的大师，我认为这让他显得非常现代。
What I want to say also is that in Corona times, locked up in our lockdowns, I tried to paint that river, that wonderful city, with my daughter. She was six years old. We are no amateurs, of course, but we had plenty of time, so we tried. Thank you, COVID.
我还想说的是，在新冠疫情封锁期间，被困在家里的我曾试图和女儿一起画那条河、那座美妙的城市。她当时六岁。当然，我们不是业余爱好者……哦不，我们是业余爱好者，但我们有充足的时间，所以我们尝试了。谢谢你，新冠。
Without that violence, I would never, but really never i would have tried to copy van eck she was six years old and i told her that if we zoom in on the boats on that river in the background of the painting that we can see that van eck painted little boat men in it knowing that those boats are not even a centimeter tall, it's incredible. And when I zoomed in on the boats and I saw, and she, my daughter, she saw the boatman, she was flabbergasted, as you will be if you do the same thing for her, for my daughter. Van Eyck will always be the painter of those tiny, teeny, tiny boatmen.
如果没有那场灾难，我绝不会、真的绝不会尝试去临摹范·埃克。她当时六岁，我告诉她，如果我们放大画作背景那条河上的船只，我们就能看到范·埃克在上面画了微型船夫，而那些船甚至连一厘米高都不到，这简直难以置信。当我放大那些船，看到那些船夫时，我女儿也看到了，她惊呆了，正如你们如果去为她——为我女儿做同样的事情时也会感到震惊一样。范·埃克将永远是那些微小、极小、极小的船夫的画家。
Oh, how wonderful. How wonderful. And just on the thing of Chancellor Roland. So he's painting a great man, a famous man, a powerful man. And this is very Renaissance, isn't it? This is the kind of thing that is going on in Italy, that all the various city states there, the dukes and so on, the doges, they have court painters to glorify them and to glorify their cities. And is that very consciously what um the dukes of burgundy are doing yes it's it was started by philip the good himself and everybody is copying it and so
噢，太美妙了。太美妙了。就罗兰大臣这件事而言，他正在画一个伟人、一个名人、一个有权势的人。这非常具有文艺复兴时期的风格，不是吗？这就像意大利正在发生的事情一样，那里的各个城邦、公爵等等、总督们，都有宫廷画师来颂扬他们和他们的城市。勃艮第公爵们这样做，是不是也是非常刻意为之的？是的，这是由菲利普良公爵本人开创的，每个人都在效仿。所以
it's it's it's of course you can say that van eck is the last painter of the middle ages and he's the first painter of the northern renaissance we have to talk about that, the individualism. Well, I think it's coming up when we're following his life. And then we come into a very modern kind of looking at Jan van Eyck. So here's a bridge between medieval art and Renaissance art in much the same way that the Duchy of Burgundy is a bridge between the medieval period and the early modern period. Would that be a fair way to characterize his status as an artist?
你可以说范·埃克既是中世纪的最后一位画家，又是北方文艺复兴的第一位画家。我们必须谈谈这一点——那种个人主义。嗯，我想当我们顺着他的生平往下看时，这一点就会显现出来。接着我们就进入了一种看待扬·范·埃克的非常现代的视角。所以，中世纪艺术与文艺复兴艺术之间存在着一座桥梁，正如勃艮第公国是中世纪与近代早期之间的一座桥梁一样。这样来描述他作为艺术家的地位是否恰当？
Yes, of course. That's completely right. I can say it better than you did. The center of Europe of that time being is Burgundy. And on the center of the court of Philip the Good, you have to see almost as a pal, a mate, someone who's really close to the Duke, you see Jan van Eyck. The first time when we really hear about him is 1425, when suddenly he's working for the Count of Holland in The Hague. And that is interesting because that count was before the Prince-Bishop of Liège.
是的，当然。完全正确。我可说不出比你更好的总结了。当时欧洲的中心是勃艮第。在菲利普良公爵的宫廷中心，你会看到扬·范·埃克——他几乎就像是一个密友、伙伴，一个与公爵非常亲近的人。我们真正听到他的消息是在1425年，当时他突然在海牙为荷兰伯爵工作。这很有趣，因为这位伯爵之前是列日的采邑主教。
So, where is he? He discovered Jan van Eyck and probably took him with him to The Hague, but not for a long time because he will be transferred to Flanders. I'd like to reconnect with the football cup metaphors and imagery. He's bought by Philip the Good andode and after long negotiations he will be transferred to another club. From now on he will be playing in the Burgundian league of Philippe
所以，他在哪里？他发现了扬·范·埃克，并很可能把他带到了海牙，但时间不长，因为他将被调往法兰德斯。我想重新联系一下世界杯足球赛的比喻和意象。他被菲利普良公爵“买下”，经过长期的谈判，他将被转会到另一家俱乐部。从现在开始，他将在菲利普·德·古德的勃艮第联赛中踢球。
de Goode. So this is like promotion to the biggest club in Europe. It's Real Madrid. It's a top. Manchester City if you want. Wolverhampton Wanderers. Yeah. And he's moving to Lille, that is now the north of France,
所以这就像是晋升到了欧洲最大的俱乐部。这就像是皇家马德里。这是一个顶级豪门。如果你愿意的话，也可以说是曼彻斯特城。狼队。对。然后他搬到了里尔，那里现在是法国北部，
but then it is Flanders. And the Duke is so enthusiastic about him. He saw his paintings, he heard about him, and he was rich. He was rich as a sheikh in Qatar, so he bought him and he could have the best painter of his time.
但当时属于法兰德斯。公爵对他是如此热情。他看过他的画作，听说过他的事迹，而且公爵很富有。他像卡塔尔的酋长一样富有，所以他把他买了下来，从而得到了他那个时代最好的画家。
And now he's living... Yes. So what is it about him that makes have the best painter of his time. And now he's living. Yes. So what is it about him that makes him the best? What is it that makes him so appealing to Philip the Good that makes him want to have this transfer with presumably a huge transfer fee as well? Well, if you want to talk about that, do you want me to say it in just one phrase
现在他住在这里……是的。那么，究竟是什么让他成为那个时代最好的画家呢？是什么让他对菲利普良公爵如此具有吸引力，让公爵甚至不惜支付巨额转会费也要把他挖过来？嗯，如果你想谈论这个，你是希望我用一句话来概括，
or do you want me to illustrate it with art? Illustrate it with art, Bart. Educate us. Yes. I also want to say that he's now at the court. I will talk about what is so special, what is so good about Van Eyck. But what we always forget, what we even don't know, is that Jan van Eyck, he what we don't, what we always forget, what we even don't know is that Jan van Eyck, he was much more than a painter. He was an ambassador. He did a lot of things. He traveled for Philip de Goethe. He made a map of the world map for Philip de Goethe. And that's, before talking about his extreme art as modernizing in the history of art, is that I want to say, and we may not forget,
还是希望我用艺术来举例说明？用艺术来举例说明吧，巴特。教导我们吧。是的。我还想说的是，他现在身处宫廷。我会谈谈范·埃克到底有什么特别之处、好在哪里。但我们总是忘记、甚至根本不知道的是，扬·范·埃克……我们不知道、我们总是忘记、甚至根本不知道的是，扬·范·埃克远不止是一位画家。他是一位外交官。他做了很多事情。他为菲利普·德·古德四处旅行。他为菲利普·德·古德绘制了一幅世界地图。在谈论他作为艺术史上现代化先驱的极致艺术之前，我想说的是，我们绝不能忘记，
that his most important thing was not his paintings at the time being, for us it is, but at the time being, he was working for the Duke and he was behind the scenery of all those banquets. Is that the one with the mechanical elephant? Yes, for instance, and how the Burgundians dressed hazel grouses in their golden habits, cooked a dozen gigantic eggs in pork bladders. Just one example. They stuffed pork bellies with strings of sausages. So when the pork was thrown to the table, that's what they did,
他在当时最重要的工作并不是他的画作——对我们来说是的，但在当时，他是为公爵工作的，他是所有这些宏大宴会背后的幕后推手。就是那个带有机械大象的宴会吗？是的，比如，勃艮第人如何给金衣雷鸟穿上盛装，用猪膀胱烹煮几十个巨大的鸡蛋。这只是一个例子。他们把香肠串塞进猪肚里。所以当猪肚被扔到桌上时——他们就是这么干的——
the belly burst open and the sausages spurped it onto the table like grandiose rosary beds. That's like the Breast is Historyories Christmas lunch with the corruption team. Yes. But next time you think of those banquets, we have to imagine behind the scenery. That is amazing. But also people like Jan van Eyck, artists who came up with the idea of 28 musicians in a gigantic pie, self-moving fake elephants, and lots of heroic tapestry and paintings in the background. So if we think of Jan van Eyck, we think of the Ghent Altarpiece,
肚子裂开，香肠像宏伟的玫瑰经念珠一样喷涌到桌上。这就像是带着腐败团队的《历史的余烬》圣诞午餐。是的。但下次当你想到那些宴会时，我们必须想象一下幕后的场景。这太惊人了。还有像扬·范·埃克这样的人，那些想出巨型馅饼里藏28个乐手、会移动的假大象、以及背景中大量英雄主义挂毯和画作点子的艺术家们。所以当我们想到扬·范·埃克时，我们会想到根特祭坛画，
but we also should think about those banquets. But he's not just working as a sort of banqueting consultant, is he? He's an ambassador and he's doing secret missions that we don't know about. Is that right? Yes. For instance, he went, we don't really know, but specialists agree that probably he went to Jerusalem to prepare a crusade for Philip the Good, to gain information for the world map he was drawing for Philip the Good, that unfortunately disappeared. And he was also sent to Portugal with other ambassadors to negotiate the marriage between Philip de Goode and Isabella of Portugal. And when the negotiations, they went well, and then he could do his real job, Van Eyck. He made a portrait of Isabella. And then he sent a portrait.
但我们也应该想到那些宴会。但他不仅仅是作为某种宴会顾问在工作，对吧？他还是一个外交官，执行着我们所不知道的秘密任务。是这样吗？是的。例如，他去了——我们其实并不完全清楚，但专家们一致认为——他很可能是去了耶路撒冷，为菲利普良公爵筹备一次十字军东征，为他当时正在绘制的世界地图（不幸的是已经失踪了）搜集情报。他还与其他外交官一起被派往葡萄牙，谈判菲利普·德·古德与葡萄牙的伊莎贝拉之间的联姻。谈判进行得很顺利，然后他就可以做他的老本行了——范·埃克画了伊莎贝拉的肖像。然后他把肖像寄了回去。
Today, we would send a photographer. Philip de Goode did better. He sent Jan van Eyck. So, Bart, would he have gone to Italy, do you think? Would he have been aware of the artistic developments there? We don't have proof of it, but everybody thinks he did, because he went to Portugal, he went to France. Why should he have been in Italy? Yeah. Yes, probably he would have been there. Should we take a break at this point? And, Bart, when we come back, could we look at what it is exactly about his art that makes him so revolutionary and radical? Maybe we should talk about self-portrait and portraiture.
今天我们会派一个摄影师。菲利普·德·古德做得更好：他派出了扬·范·埃克。所以，巴特，你认为他去过意大利吗？他会了解那里的艺术发展吗？我们没有证据，但大家都认为他去过，因为他去过葡萄牙，去过法国。他为什么就不能去过意大利呢？是的，是的，他很可能去过。我们是不是应该在这个时候休息一下？巴特，当我们回来时，能不能看看他的艺术究竟有何精妙之处，使其如此富有革命性和激进色彩？也许我们应该谈谈自画像和肖像画。
Yeah. And we should talk about the Ghent Altarpiece. Yeah, that's what we'll do. So we'll do that after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is history we are talking to bart van lo or i should say bart van lo is really talking at us um i think that is uh i know no i say that that is what we want that is absolutely what we want i don't want to hear from tom holland at all in the next 40 minutes or 30
对。我们还应该谈谈根特祭坛画。对，这就是我们要做的。所以我们在休息之后再谈这个。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的权益，请访问 theredisentertainment.com。这里是《历史的余烬》，我们正在与巴特·范·卢对话——或者我应该说，巴特·范·卢简直是在对我们狂轰滥炸。嗯，我觉得这……我知道，不，我说过，这正是我们想要的，绝对是我们想要的。在接下来的40分钟或30分钟里，我一点也不想听汤姆·霍兰说话，
minutes or whatever it is i just want to hear from you. Here's a question for you to kick off. Did Jan van Eyck invent oil painting? No, he didn't. We know that oil painting existed way before. We have proof that it was used by other people. But the craftsmanship of Jan van Eyck, it relies down to his control of all painting. He did introduce improvements to the process and therefore he can be seen as one of the originators. And now it's a little bit technical and I'm not that kind of specialist, but it's interesting to know that what changed is that suddenly painters, they use linseed oil instead of egg yolk as a medium.
或者不管多长时间，我只想听你讲。这里有一个问题供你开场：扬·范·埃克发明了油画吗？不，他没有。我们知道油画在很久以前就已经存在了。我们有证据表明其他人也使用过它。但扬·范·埃克的手艺在于他对油画技法的精湛掌控。他确实对工艺进行了改进，因此可以被视为先驱之一。这可能有点技术性，而且我也不是这方面的专家，但了解这一点很有趣：当时发生的变化是，画家们突然开始用亚麻仁油代替蛋黄作为调和剂。
And that enables painters to impart far more shimmering quality to their colors than they had ever had done before. And van Eyck is experimenting with adding secretives. That's a chemical melange of metals, which made the oil paint dry more quickly. And then it gives him the possibility. He was able to superimpose transparent layers of paint in an innovative way. And as a result, he succeeded in creating the illusion of real death and in giving more luster to the colors. The blue sky are more luminous than ever. The grass was greener and the gold was no longer the shiny effect that his predecessors had achieved by using gold leaf. His gold looked like real gold. So Bart, part of what makes him revolutionary then is this technical ability he has. He's going down deep into the kind of the chemistry of the paint, coming up with a bit like Leonardo does later, I suppose, but obviously to better effect because his paint hasn't kind of flaked and fallen away.
这使得画家能够赋予色彩远超以往的闪耀质感。范·埃克还在试验中加入了催干剂——这是一种金属化学混合物，能使油画颜料干得更快。这赋予了他一种可能性：他能够以创新方式叠加透明的颜料层。结果，他成功地创造出了真实深度的幻觉，并赋予了色彩更多光泽。蓝天比以往任何时候都更加明亮，草地更绿了，金色也不再是其前辈使用金箔所达到的那种单调闪亮效果。他的金色看起来就像真正的黄金。所以，巴特，他之所以具有革命性，部分原因就在于这种技术能力？他深入研究了颜料的化学成分，想出了一些类似于后来达·芬奇所做的事情，显然效果更好，因为他的颜料没有像达·芬奇的画那样剥落脱落。
But what about the way that he's then using this paint? Are there things, aspects about the paintings themselves, the images that are on the canvas or on the wall or whatever that is radical and new? Yes, of course. I would like to talk about two things, portrait and then the Ghent altarpiece. Okay. The portrait, we talked about the portrait of Isabella of Portugal, but we also have the portrait of a man in red turban.
但他在使用这种颜料的方式上呢？画作本身、画布或墙壁上的图像，是否存在激进且崭新的方面？是的，当然。我想谈两点：肖像画，然后是根特祭坛画。好的。关于肖像画，我们之前谈到了葡萄牙的伊莎贝拉的肖像，但我们还有那幅《红头巾男子肖像》（Portrait of a Man in a Red Turban）。
And that is believed to be one of the first self-portraits in history, we better say, I think the oldest preserved work of this kind. And talking about portraits, there are several known examples of portraits, and I think Tom can explain it far better than me, but there are a lot of examples of portraits from antiquity. But the practice practically vanished with the emergence of Christianity, which maintained a long and troubled relationship with human representations in general and representations of Christ in particular. And it wasn't until the 14th century that an
人们认为这是历史上最早的自画像之一，或者更确切地说，是同类作品中现存最古老的一幅。说到肖像画，有几个著名的肖像画范例，我想汤姆能比我解释得好得多，但古代有很多肖像画的例子。然而，随着基督教的兴起，这种实践实际上消失了。基督教与一般的人形表现形式（尤其是对基督的表现形式）保持着一种漫长而困扰的关系。直到14世纪，
art of portraiture developed that was worthy of the name, often used in connection with Marius' negotiations of simply to keep dead or imprisoned prints symbolically alive, present. And labeling Van Eyck as the grandmaster of portrait is a truth difficult to dispute, but we cannot see him as an artistic extraterrestrial. He's not the ET of art history. And often we think about him as the ET of art history, as somebody who simply fell out of the sky. And that is an exaggeration.
一种名副其实的肖像艺术才发展起来，通常与婚姻谈判或仅仅为了象征性地让死去或被囚禁的王子们保持生机与在场联系在一起。将范·埃克贴上肖像画宗师的标签是一个无可争辩的事实，但我们不能把他看作是一个艺术上的“外星人”。他不是艺术史上的ET。人们常常把他看作艺术史上的ET，仿佛他是凭空从天上掉下来的一样。这是一种夸张。
Even on basis of the few available examples, it is obvious that he is following in the footsteps of Burgundian painters such as Marlwall and Broederlam. But he outshone them with his eye for detail, the incidence of light from an unseen source, etc. And look at that man in red turban. And you have to go to the National Gallery in London.
即使根据现有的少数几个例子来看，也很明显他是在追随勃艮第画家的脚步，比如马尔鲁（Maelwael）和布鲁德勒姆（Broederlam）。但他以自己对细节的敏锐眼光、来自不可见光源的光线入射等超越了他们。看看那个红头巾的男子。你得去伦敦的国家美术馆看看。
You see the hat and the turban stand out in sharp detail while the background is black. Vastly different for the rather flat and stylized faces of Grudelam and Marlwall. It's incredible. It's still astonishing. It's three-dimensional. I'm looking at it now. It is genuinely, it feels three-dimensional in a way that his predecessors don't at all. His mastery of kind of shadow and texture.
你可以看到帽子和头巾以鲜明的细节突显出来，而背景则是黑色的。这与布鲁德勒姆和马尔鲁那些相当扁平且风格化的面孔有着天壤之别。这太不可思议了。至今仍令人震撼。它是三维立体的。我现在正看着它。它真实地、以一种他的前辈们完全没有的方式让人感觉具有三维立体感。他对阴影和质感的掌控……
And yeah, I'm not an art critic, so I don't have the vocabulary. That was really good, Dominic. That was really good, Dominic. That was really good. But just thinking about another, possibly even more famous painting by Van Eyck in the National Gallery in London, which is probably the painting by him that will be most familiar to British listeners because it's in London, is the Arnolfini portrait, which shows a kind of a merchant and his wife. So the paintings you've been talking about up till now have been either Van Eyck himself or people from the very upper echelons of society, prime ministers and princesses and whatever. But this presumably is a lower social class. But it's somebody with a lot of money and he wants to imitate the Duke, wants to imitate Roland. And that's the kind of thing that is happening. People who have money want themselves on a painting. And that is quite new. And this is something that is really distinctive about the
是的，我不是艺术评论家，所以我没有这方面的词汇。那真的很好，多米尼克。那真的很好，多米尼克。那真的很好。但回想起另一幅范·埃克可能更著名的画作，同样在伦敦国家美术馆里——由于它在伦敦，这可能是英国听众对他的作品最熟悉的一幅——那就是《阿尔诺芬尼夫妇像》（Arnolfini Portrait），描绘了一个商人和他的妻子。所以你刚才谈到的画作要么是范·埃克本人，要么是社会最上层的权贵，比如首相和公主之流。但这张画描绘的显然是一个较低社会阶层的人。不过这是一个很有钱的人，他想要模仿公爵，想要模仿罗兰。这正是当时正在发生的事情：有钱的人想要把自己的形象画在画上。这相当新颖。而这正是
whole of the lowlands. It's this kind of bourgeois, rising, proto-capitalist society that will become the great motor of what becomes capitalism into the 16th and 17th centuries. And the portraits of Arnolfini and Rollin and others, they were fully consistent with the greater picture of growing individualism. The fact that the painter was all too eager to warm himself at this gently building bonfire of divinities. It could be seen also in his so-called self-portrait, but also in the completion of the Arnolfino portrait. When you are before that portrait in the National Gallery,
整个低地国家真正与众不同的地方：这是一种资产阶级的、正在崛起的、准资本主义的社会，它将成为16世纪和17世纪资本主义大发展的巨大发动机。阿尔诺芬尼、罗兰和其他人的肖像，完全符合不断增长的个人主义这一宏大画面。画家急于在这团缓缓燃起的独立于神权的篝火中取暖，这一点也可以从他所谓的自画像以及阿尔诺芬尼肖像的完成中看出。当你站在伦敦国家美术馆的那幅肖像画前时，
you see that right in the middle of that work, he wrote literally, Johannes de Eick, Fwitt, Hick, Jan van Eyck was here. And in the mirror, hanging beneath that inscription, we can just make out his own silhouette. Yeah, that's the remarkable thing about it, isn't it? So the art critic Ernst Gombrich, he said that it's one of the great revolutionary works of art. A simple corner of the real world had suddenly been fixed onto a panel
你会看到，就在那件作品的正中央，他 literalmente（字面意义地）写下了：“Johannes de Eyck fuit hic”——扬·范·埃克曾在此。而在那行铭文下方悬挂的镜子里，我们刚好能辨认出他自己的剪影。是的，这正是它非凡的地方，不是吗？所以艺术评论家恩斯特·贡布里奇（Ernst Gombrich）曾说，这是伟大的革命性艺术作品之一。现实世界的一个简单角落突然之间被固定在了一块木板上，
as if by magic. For the first time in history, the artist became the perfect eyewitness in the truest sense of the term. And that's what you're saying. He is present in the painting in a way that an artist had never really been present in a painting before. Yes, present. And he is the first artist we know who put his name on his panels, on his paintings. He just put his name or a slogan, something like,
仿佛是通过某种魔法。历史上第一次，艺术家成为了真正意义上最完美的目击者。这就是你所说的：他以一种艺术家以前从未有过的方式存在于画作之中。是的，在场。而且他是我们所知道的第一个将自己的名字写在木板画、写在画作上的艺术家。他只是写下他的名字或一句格言，比如：
Als ich kam, which means that he completed this work as well as I'm able, given my devotion and ability. That's a sardonic quip from an artist who knew perfectly well what he was capable of. He wrote his name at the bottom of the frame.
“Als ich can”（尽我所能），这意味着他倾注了自己的奉献与才华，尽其所能地完成了这件作品。这是一个深谙自己能力的艺术家发出的辛辣俏皮话。他在画框底部写下了自己的名字。
And also the Ghent Altarpiece contains a clear reference to Jan van Eyck. Just before we go to the Ghent Altarpiece, you said he wasn't E.T. He didn't fall from the sky. So that putting himself into the painting and that sort of sense of a move to –'m not i'm trying to i'm still groping for my art criticism terminology so so this sort of sense that he is an eyewitness looking at a particular scene and that his individual it's you know it's his individual viewpoint that we are seeing rather than some sort of abstract sort of absolute dehumanized vision. Is that coming out of the kind of, is that a, you know, is he reflecting a kind of humanism and an individualism of his time or is that unique to
根特祭坛画也包含了对扬·范·埃克的清晰署名。在我们讨论根特祭坛画之前，你刚才说他不是ET，他不是从天而降的。所以把自己画进画里，以及那种向——我不是在……我还在摸索我的艺术批评术语——所以这种他作为一个目击者在观察特定场景的感觉，以及我们看到的其实是他的个人视角，而不是某种抽象的、绝对的、非人化的视觉。这是源于……这是一种……你知道的，他是在反映他那个时代的人文主义和个人主义，还是这是他独有的？
him? No, it is happening, but he's very, he's the most extravagant example of it. But we also have, for instance, the Dukes of Burgundy, somebody like Philip the Bold, the first Duke of Burgundy. He will put a statue of himself at the entrance of his church in Dijon, Chamonix. It's completely new. And the monks in Cluny, when they made, Tom will know that better than me, when they made a statue of God or Christ, they were afraid that there was thunder coming from the skies. They were hiding in somewhere where they could hide, but nothing happened. God didn't do anything.
不，这正在发生，但他其中最极端的例子。但我们也有其他的例子，例如勃艮第公爵们，像勇敢的菲利普（Philip the Bold，第一代勃艮第公爵）。他在第戎的萨莫尔奇教堂入口处放置了自己的雕像。这完全是崭新的。而克吕尼的修道士们在制作上帝或基督的雕像时——汤姆会比我更清楚这一点——他们曾担心会有雷电从天而降。他们躲在某个可以藏身的地方，但什么也没发生。上帝什么也没做。
So people went on, and then at the end of the fourth and beginning of the 15th century, things are changing. And in what is changing everywhere, you could say there's something in the water. We cannot explain it. Maybe Tom can explain it. Van Eyck is on the top of it. He's saying, here I am. I'm putting my name and that's what's happening now. So he's clearly reflecting the spirit of the age. He's reflecting the spirit that is the court of the Burgundian dukes, but also this rising merchant class. However, if we look at the painting that we're going to close with, the Ghent altarpiece, this great altarpiece in the church in Ghent, talk us through that. To what extent is that? Because this, in a way, does seem to me to be looking
于是人们继续前进。到了14世纪末和15世纪初，事情正在发生变化。在所有这些正在发生变化的地方，你可以说空气中弥漫着某种东西。我们无法解释它。也许汤姆能解释。范·埃克正站在这一切的巅峰。他在说：“我在这里。我写下了我的名字，这就是现在正在发生的事。”所以他显然反映了时代的精神。他反映了勃艮第公爵宫廷的精神，也反映了这种正在崛起的商人阶层的精神。然而，如果我们看一看我们将要作为收尾的画作——根特祭坛画，这座位于根特教堂的伟大祭坛画，请给我们讲讲。在多大程度上……因为这在某种程度上，在我看来至少和向前看一样，也是在向后看。我可能理解错了。所以，如果你正在听这个播客，并且能够用手机或其他设备把它调出来看一看，请务必这么做。但对于那些无法查看的人，你能描述一下这座祭坛画吗？不，这不可能。这怎么可能呢？我们首先要想象的是，这座祭坛画是合上的。让我们把它合上。
backwards at least as much as forwards. I may have that wrong. So if you're listening to this podcast and you are able to call it up on your phone or wherever you are, do. But just for those who can't, could you give a description of the altarpiece? No, it's impossible. It's impossible. How could you? The first thing we have to imagine is that this altarpiece is closed. Let's close it.
它合上了。让我们想象我们身处根特，在古老的圣约翰教堂里（该教堂在16世纪被重命名为圣巴夫主教座堂）。我们就在那里。那是1432年5月6日。我们为了根特祭坛画的落成典礼而在那里。这是欧洲艺术的杰作。此外，它还是世界的
It's closed. And let's imagine we are there in Ghent, in the old church of St. John, which was renamed the St. Bavo Cathedral in the 16th century. We are there. It is 6 May 1432. And we are there for the installation of the Ghent Altarpiece. A masterpiece of European art. Moreover, one of the world's
瑰宝之一。我们有米开朗基罗的大卫雕塑，我们有达·芬奇的《蒙娜丽莎》，我们有伦勃朗的《夜巡》，我们还有根特祭坛画。这是一件不容错过的杰作。一座几乎无与伦比的艺术里程碑。让我们想象一下，菲利普良公爵也在那里，与他的
treasures. We have the David sculpture of Michelangelo. We have the Mona Lisa of Da Vinci. We have the Night Watch of Rembrandt. And we have the Ghent Altarpiece. It's a must. An artistic landmark almost beyond comparison. And let's imagine Philip the Good is there too, with his
妻子葡萄牙的伊莎贝拉在一起。我们还看到了另外两个非常重要的人：约斯·韦特（Jos Veth）和伊丽莎白·博吕特（Elizabeth Borluut）。我必须提到他们，因为没有他们，就不会有这件杰作。他们是这座多联画屏祭坛画的赞助人和出资人。他们膝下无子，没有人来延续家族姓氏。但多亏了这座祭坛画，他们将名垂青史。甚至他们可以确信，整整590年之后，汤姆·霍兰和多米尼克·桑德布鲁克会在《历史的余烬》播客中了解他们。简而言之，他们知道自己可以死而无憾了。我们依然
wife, Isabella of Portugal. And we see also two other people, very important, Jos Veth and Elizabeth Berlut. I have to mention them because without them, we wouldn't have had this masterpiece. And they are the person who commissioned and paid for this polyptych altarpiece. They remained childless and there was no one to carry the family name forward. But thanks to this altarpiece, they will go on in history. Even they are sure that exactly 590 years later, Tom Holland and Dominic Sandbrook will learn about them on the Rest is History podcast. In short, they know they can die in peace. And we have still,
在合上的祭坛画前，我们还必须想象扬·范·埃克本人显赫地出现在视线中，介于约斯·韦特和菲利普·德·古德之间——这位艺术家成为了他那个时代精英之间的桥梁建造者。我们就站在韦特小教堂里，站在合上的祭坛画前。我们看到了背面的画板。为什么它是合上的？
before the closed altarpiece, we have also to imagine Jan van Eyck himself prominently in view, somewhere between Jos Veth and Philip de Goed, the artist as a bridge builder between the elites of his age. And there we are in the Veth Chapel in builder between the elites of his age. And there we are in the VAT chapel in front of the closed altar piece. We see the back panels. And why is it closed?
那是信徒们在平常日子里看到的景象。它只在星期天和节假日才打开。是的，我们也在那里。假设我们是赞助人约斯·韦特肩膀上的一只苍蝇，我们脑子里想的只有一件事：如果他和他的妻子博吕特穿着和范·埃克为背面画板所绘肖像中一模一样的衣服——也就是我们现在看到的画面——他们一定会发誓说，他们两个人正站在一面镜子前。范·埃克的现实主义刻画深入骨髓。约斯·韦特，他甚至可以数清他那双下巴、三下巴。
That is what the faithful, the believers see on normal days. It's only opened on Sundays and holidays. And yes, we are there too. Let's say we are a fly on the shoulders of Commissioner Josveit and all we can think of is this. If that and his wife Burlut wore the same clothes as the portals made by Van Eyck for the back panels, that is what we are looking at now, they would have sworn that the two of them were standing in front of a mirror. Van Eyck is realistic to the bone. Jos Vat, he can count his double, triple chins
这就是信徒们在平常日子里看到的。它只在周日和节假日打开。是的环节我们也在那里。假设我们是挂在约斯菲特特员肩膀上的一只苝蝇。我们能想到的只有这个。如果他和他的妻子布鲁鲁特穿着与范基克为背板制作的壞门相同的衣服——这就是我们现在正在看着的——他们会发誓他们俩就好像站在镜子前一样。范基克的创作到了骨子里的面。约斯·瓦特的双重三重双颌子他都数得清楚
and all his warts. And of course, I talk about it. This portrait of the patron is also consistent with this greater picture of growing individualism. But let's now open again Altarpiece. Let's open it quickly. It's gleaming, shining in the middle. The mystic lamp symbolizing the sacrifice of Jesus, of course, but also we see a sheep in the end of the late Middle Ages, thanks to the cloth weaving industry, thanks to the wool of English sheep. Jan was not only into religious symbolism when he put the sheep in the center of this painting.
连同他所有的瑕疵。当然，我也会谈到这一点。赞助人的这幅肖像画也符合这种日益增长的个人主义的宏大画面。但现在让我们再次打开祭坛画。让我们快点打开它。它在中间闪闪发光。神秘的羔羊象征着耶稣的牺牲，当然，我们也在中世纪晚期看到了绵羊，多亏了呢绒织造业，多亏了英国羊的羊毛。扬·凡·艾克把绵羊放在这幅画的中心时，并不只是为了宗教象征。
And there is more. I imagine that seeing this must have made Philip the Good reach for his chest in an involuntary reflex, seeing a reflection of the golden ram he wore around his neck. Yes, of course. In the image of the sheep, the emblem of the golden fleece. Isn't that wonderful? That puts lots of layers in his work. And of course, I'm not going to give a theological interpretation of the work of who we'll still be talking tomorrow. But, I mean, that's just one of the many images on the altarpiece, isn't it?
还有更多。我猜，看到这一幕一定让善良的菲利普出于下意识的本能摸向自己的胸口，看到了他脖子上佩戴的金羊毛的倒影。是的，当然。在羊的形象中，正是金羊毛的标志。这不是太棒了吗？这为他的作品增添了许多层次。当然，我不会对这件作品进行神学解读，我们明天还会继续讨论。但是，我的意思是，这只是祭坛画上的众多意象之一，不是吗？
I mean, you've got all these biblical characters. You have knights. You have, I don't know, a crowd of worshippers. You have somebody playing an organ or some musical instrument. Adam and Eve. Adam and Eve. Adam and Eve. And it is, I mean, people should Google it and be looking at it now. It is incredibly realistic, but it is also sumptuous, kind of technicolor.
我的意思是，里面有所有这些圣经人物。有骑士。有，我不知道，一大群朝拜者。有人在弹管风琴或某种乐器。亚当和夏娃。亚当和夏娃。亚当和夏娃。而且，我的意思是，人们应该去谷歌一下，现在就看一看。它极其逼真，但同时也极其华丽，带有一种特艺七彩（technicolor）的感觉。
I mean, have you been to Ghent Cathedral, Tom? I have, yes. I mean, when you see it in the flesh, it's an amazing, amazing piece of work. Yes, you talk about Adam, and that reminds me of something. When you see Adam, that's on the back channel, but that's not important. But when you look at him, particularly at his hair, it looks as if we can see, as if we can touch every single hair. But that is not true. Van Eyck, of course, did not paint paint every single hair but it gives us the illusion that he did so and that is the magic of Jan van Eyck so but what's going on here what does all this mean so it's God the Virgin John the Baptist there's a lot of Holy Spirit action going on
我的意思是，你去过根特大教堂吗，汤姆？我去过，是的。我的意思是，当你亲眼看到它时，它是一件令人惊叹、叹为观止的杰作。是的，你谈到了亚当，这让我想起了一些事情。当你看到亚当的时，那是在后台频道，但这并不重要。但当你看着他，尤其是他的头发时，看起来仿佛我们可以看到，仿佛我们可以触摸到每一根头发。但事实并非如此。凡·艾克当然没有画出每一根头发，但他给我们造成了他画了的错觉，这就是扬·凡·艾克的魔力所在。那么，这里到底发生了什么？这一切意味着什么？所以这是上帝、圣母、施洗约翰，还有很多圣灵的活动在进行。
what else is happening yes but no but no, but that is, it's, it's, it's impossible to talk about it. There are so many details you could talk about. That detail reminds that place in Gant or in Bruges, that detail. We can,
还发生了什么？是的，但是不，但是不，但那是，这是，这是无法用言语表达的。有太多的细节你可以谈论。那个细节让人想起根特或布鲁日的那处地方，那个细节。我们可以，
if we can, the angels who are singing, they are, they are looking at the book and you can read what they are singing. Yeah. It's incredible. When you see a book closed, you see there is a note in it. The book is closed, but I imagine that if we could,
如果可以的话，那些正在唱歌的天使，他们在，他们在看着书，你可以读出他们在唱什么。是的。这太不可思议了。当你看到一本合上的书时，你会发现里面有一张纸条。书是合上的，但我想如果我们能够，
with some technology, take the note in the book, we could take it out. Jan van Eyck, I'm sure he has written something on it. That is the idea you get when you're in front of the Ghent Altarpiece. When it is opened in what, 1432, did you say, Bart? 1432, it's 519 years ago. Is that pretty much the peak of Ghent's kind of power and influence? Yes, Ghent was big in the 13th century, in the 14th century, in the 15th century. But at that moment being, it's the biggest city in Northern Europe. Of course, there is Paris, but Ghent is almost up to 70, maybe 80,000 people.
用某种技术把书里的纸条拿出来，我们可以把它拿出来。扬·艾克，我确信他在上面写了些什么。这就是你站在根特祭坛画前时的感受。当它在1432年被打开时，巴特，你刚才说是1432年吗？1432年，那是519年前。这差不多是根特权力和影响力的巅峰时期吗？是的，根特在13世纪、14世纪、15世纪都很强大。但就在那个时刻，它是北欧最大的城市。当然，还有巴黎，但根特的总人口几乎达到了7万，甚至8万。
That's huge because in 1350 in Amsterdam, there were only a thousand people in maybe three, four, five000 at the moment when the Ghent Altarpiece was opened. Everything is happening in Flanders, in Ghent, in Bruges. And that's where we see the Duke, where we see the Dutchers, where we see Jos Vat and Jan van Eyck in front of this masterpiece. It's a classic example of how the generation of wealth generates art. People become rich, they can afford to pay brilliant artists. And so in a way, this is a monument not just to a kind of cultural highlight, but an age of political and economic power, which of course is what your great book about the Burgundians is all about. Yes, it is. And people today, what strikes them when they are before van Eyck is the details, the realism. Did you know that there is another painting, The Virgin and Child with Canon van der Palen,
这太庞大了，因为在1350年的阿姆斯特丹，只有大约一千人，在根特祭坛画揭幕时也只有三、四、五千人。一切都发生在佛兰德斯，在根特，在布鲁日。这就是我们看到公爵、看到公爵夫人、看到约斯·维特和扬·凡·艾克站在这个杰作前的地方。这是财富的产生如何产生艺术的经典例子。人们变得富有，他们买得起优秀的艺术家。因此，在某种程度上，这不仅是文化巅峰的纪念碑，也是一个政治和经济权力的时代，当然，这正是你关于勃艮第人的伟大书籍所讲述的内容。
that Einstein, as the doctors who studied that painting, that they are able today to diagnose the clergyman's arteriosclerosis. Wow. And just how fascinated the group of Burgundians must have been in 1432 as they gazed at the Ghent altarpiece. They'd probably never beheld such flagrant realism before. Well, that's it, isn't it? It's the combination of the sort of theological complexity
是的，确实如此。今天的人们，当他们站在凡·艾克面前时，最震撼他们的是细节、现实主义。你知道还有另一幅画吗，《圣母子与卡农·范·德·帕勒》，
with the same realism that he's bringing to men with blue hats or men with red hats or all the portraits that he has previously been painting. And that, I guess, is something new because people had not attempted to bring realism into sort of religious art because the whole point of religious art was that it wasn't meant to be realistic. So it is because I always ask myself, technically, there must have been someone in the 13th century who would have more or less could have done what did Van Eyck. But why did we have to wait till that moment?
爱因斯坦，正如研究这幅画的医生们所说，他们今天能够诊断出这位神职人员的动脉硬化。哇。1432年，当勃艮第人凝视根特祭坛画时，他们该有多么着迷啊。他们以前可能从未见过如此昭然若揭的现实主义。嗯，就是这样，不是吗？这是那种神学复杂性的结合，
That is what you're talking about, that things are changing. And suddenly, with science going on, with the growth of individualism of the ego, and with the lots of money that we have in Burgundy, in Ghent and Bruges, we can make this kind of art. Just before we go, one last question. When you cheer Belgium on in the World Cup, do you secretly wish that there was a Burgundian team? Ah, yes, because it would be great. Imagine that we would have a Burgundian team
同时运用了他之前画戴蓝帽子的人、戴红帽子的人或所有肖像画时所采用的现实主义。我想，这是前所未有的，因为人们以前从未试图将现实主义引入某种宗教艺术中，因为宗教艺术的全部意义在于它不应该是现实主义的。所以这是因为我经常问自己，从技术上讲，在13世纪一定有人或多或少能够做到凡·艾克所做的事情。但为什么我们非得等到那个时刻呢？
that would make the Netherlands and Belgium together. I don't know, we would have won three or four World Cups. We would have beaten the Argentines in 78. We would have beaten the Spanish, where was it, 20 years ago. And imagine the opening ceremony that he would have designed, Van Eyck would have designed. Loads of elephants, sausages everywhere. It would have been brilliant. You'd have given the Dutch some much needed backbone to stop them crumbling in World Cup finals, Bart. That's what you'd have done.
这就是你所说的，事情正在发生变化。突然之间，随着科学的发展，随着个人主义和自我意识的增长，以及我们在勃艮第、根特和布鲁日拥有的巨额资金，我们可以创作出这种艺术。在我们离开之前，最后一个问题。当你在世界杯上为比利时加油时，你是否暗自希望有一支勃艮第球队？啊，是的，因为那太棒了。想象一下，如果我们有一支勃艮第球队，
Yes, that would be great. It would be great. We would be a great power in Europe. But let's just, just before we say goodbye, Jan van Eyck, he dies in 1441 in Bruges. And is there a sense then when he dies that Burgundy has lost one of the great figures in European cultural history? Yes, that is there because he was an example. There are other great painters coming on.
那将把荷兰和比利时结合在一起。我不知道，我们本可以赢得三到四次世界杯。我们本可以在78年击败阿根廷人。我们本可以在20年，还是在哪里的，击败西班牙人。想象一下他会设计的开幕式，凡·艾克会设计它。满载的象群，到处都是香肠。那将是精彩绝伦的。你给荷兰人提供了一些急需的脊梁骨，阻止他们在世界杯决赛中崩盘，巴特。这就是你会做的事。
His successor on the Burgundian court is someone like Rogier van der Weyden. You could also do a podcast on him. I think we would be too tempted to call him Roger van der Weyden so that people in England knew who he was. How did you say it again? Rogier van der Weyden. And that is interesting because he was Roger de la Pasteur. He had a name in French, but because of the Burgundian Flemish court,
是的，那会很棒。那会很棒。我们将成为欧洲的一大强国。但在我们告别之前，扬·凡·艾克于1441年在布鲁日逝世。当他去世时，人们是否觉得勃艮第失去了一位欧洲文化史上的伟大人物？是的，确实有这种感觉，因为他是一个榜样。还有其他伟大的画家崭露头角。
he translated his name in Dutch. We need more of this linguistic education, Tom, don't you think? We do. Yes, we do. And there's been a lot of butchering of languages in the Brest's history. And it's good that someone's come on to put us right, especially over this um world cup uh sweep can i give the last tip to to to the listeners of course not everybody can go to again not everybody can go to london to see arnold feeney to the louvre to the for the madonna with chancellor roland which is in restoration right now i cannot wait
他在勃艮第宫廷的继任者是像罗吉尔·范德韦登这样的人。你也可以为他做一个播客。我想我们太想叫他罗杰·范德韦登了，好让英国人知道他是谁。你刚才怎么说来着？罗吉尔·范德韦登。这很有趣，因为他曾叫罗杰·德·拉帕斯特尔。他有一个法语法文名字，但因为勃艮第佛兰德斯宫廷，
to see the results and the g Ghent altarpiece has been restored and it's magnificent. When we are now in front of the Ghent altarpiece, we can see it with the eyes of Van Eyck and Philip de Goethe. It's the same colors as 600 years ago. But what I want to say is there is an incredible solution for this problem.
他把自己的名字翻译成了荷兰语。我们需要更多的这种语言教育，汤姆，你不觉得吗？我们确实需要。是的，我们确实需要。布雷斯特的历史上有很多对语言的肆意篡改。很高兴有人来纠正我们，尤其是关于这次世界杯的抽奖，我可以给听众们最后一个建议吗？当然，不是每个人都能去根特，不是每个人都能去伦敦看阿尔诺芬尼夫妇，去卢浮宫看正在修复中的罗兰坎切勒圣母像，我简直等不及了
Listen very carefully. I will say this only once. Go to the website closer to Van Eyck. It's a digital project where you can zoom into the minor details of these masterpieces and yes you can see the teeny tiny boatman on the madonna painting and you don't know what you are seeing it's wonderful and you can only fall in love with jan van eick we have all fallen in love with jan van eck as we fell in love with the court of Burgundy in your previous episode but thanks so much absolute champion of Burgundy
看修复结果了，根特祭坛画已经修复好了，它太壮观了。当我们现在站在根特祭坛画前时，我们可以用凡·艾克和善良的菲利普的眼睛去欣赏它。它的颜色和600年前一模一样。但我想说的是，有一个不可思议的解决方案可以解决这个问题。
and of course therefore for Belgium thanks very much thanks so much all of you for listening bye bye goodbye thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
听好了。我只说一次。去“走近凡·艾克”（Closer to Van Eyck）网站。这是一个数字项目，你可以放大这些杰作的微小细节，是的，你可以在圣母画上看到那个极小的船夫，你甚至不知道自己看到了什么，这太奇妙了，你只会爱上扬·凡·艾克。我们所有人都爱上了扬·凡·艾克，正如我们在上一集中爱上勃艮第宫廷一样，非常感谢你，勃艮第的绝对冠军，
That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当然也是比利时的冠军。非常感谢，非常感谢大家的收听，再见，再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家剧集、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。